BEGIN THE INFORMATIONAL HEARING
ON THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET
PACKAGE.
WE ARE GOING TO START WITH.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH S. B.
EIGHT FORTY WHICH IS THE BUDGET
BILL.
MISS COSTA. EIGHT EIGHT FORTY
EIGHT FORTY I THINK YOU'RE SB A
FORTY IS THE BUDGET BILL IN
PRINCIPLE BEFORE THE COMMITTEE A
CONTAINS MANY OF THE PROVISIONS
THAT WE DISCUSS IN CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE LATE LAST WEEK WITHOUT
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU GOING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE OR COLLAPSE
[inaudible]
MISTER WHAT.
MISS COST US SO WE'VE HAD MANY
MANY DISCUSSIONS OVER THE LAST
WEEK AND A HALF ON THIS --
WHEN ALL THE DUST IS SETTLED NOW
WE'VE GOT WHAT IS PRETTY A
FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE BUDGET HERE?
BUT WITH THE EXCEPTION THE FACT
THAT WE'RE STILL INCREASING
STATE SPENDING MY OVER 9% WHEN
WE DID THE MATH SO JUST CURIOUS
AT THE DISNEY ADMINISTRATION
CONSIDER THAT A REASONABLE.
LEVEL OF INCREASE YOUR HEREBY
CAPE WE JUST WERE NOT ERA WHEN --
INFLATION IS RUNNING ABOUT 3%
AND STATE POPULATION GROWTH IS
UNDER 1% SO.
A 9% INCREASE IN STATE SPENDING
SEEMS A LITTLE ALARMING
WHICHEVER THAT --
AYE IT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING
THAT WE LOOK AT I WOULD KNOW
THAT STATE SPENDING IS
PREDICATED ON SEVERAL DIFFERENT
FACTORS INCLUDING CASELOAD
GROWTH ON IN SOME OF OUR
PROGRAMS INCLUDING AND CAL GRANT
FOR EXAMPLE ARE CAL WORKS --
AS WELL AND I'VE KNOW THERE ARE
SOME AND INCREASES ASSOCIATED
WITH A NEW PROGRAMS BUT FOR THE
MOST PART WE'VE REALLY TRIED TO
LIMIT THOSE TO HAVE BEEN ONE
TIME IN NATURE [inaudible]
THANK YOU AS FAR.
I JUST BE LOUDER --
JUST DON'T WALK ME THROUGH THE
NUMBER RESERVE ACCOUNTS THAT ARE
NOW IN THE BUDGET.
AND HOW THEY FUNCTION TOGETHER.
SURE THERE WILL BE AN ITEM LATER
ON IN THE AGENDA WITH THE
SPECIFIC NEW RESERVE ACCOUNTS
BUT RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
PROPOSITION TWO WHICH IS THE
CONSTITUTIONAL BUDGET AS
STABILIZATION ACCOUNT.
I WHICH WE HAVE PROPOSED IN THE
FINAL BUDGET AGREEMENT DOES
FULLY FUNDS THE CONSTITUTIONAL
TARGET.
WE HAVE WHAT'S KNOWN AS THE SFE
YOU'RE THE STATE FUND FOR
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTIES THAT'S
WHAT WE UTILIZE IN TIMES OF
DISASTER OR FOR THINGS THAT
HAPPENED AFTER THE AYE BUDGET
BILL IN PRINCIPLE HAS BEEN
PASSED.
THE TWO NEW ADDITIONS ARE --
THE SENATE HAD PROPOSED AND
WE'VE ACCEPTED --
THE SAFETY NET UP RESERVE FUND
WHICH WOULD INCLUDED A POSITIVE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME IT HAS TO SUB ACCOUNTS ONE
FOR CAO WORKS.
ON AND ONE FOR MEDI CAL.
I'M IT CREATES THE FIRST DEPOSIT
INTO THE CAL WORKS SUB ACCOUNT.
AND THEN LASTLY WE HAVE THE
BUDGET DEFICIT SAVINGS ACCOUNT
WHICH WILL WORK AS A MECHANISM
FOR THE PROP TWO PAYMENTS.
IT'S PREDICATED ON OUR REVENUES
THAT NUMBER CHANGES OVER TIME
I'M WE HAVE A NUMBER OF TRUE UP
PROVISIONS.
SO WE WILL A DEPOSIT THE DOLLARS
INTO THAT ACCOUNT THEY WILL STAY
THERE ANA AND TELL WE KNOW THE
FINAL AMOUNT REQUIRED TO BRING
AND THE BUDGET STABILIZATION
ACCOUNT UP TO THE CONSTITUTIONAL
TARGET.
ANY DOLLARS THAT ARE IN THE
ACCOUNT THAT ARE BEYOND THAT
WENT BACK CALCULATION IS MADE.
50% WILL STAY IN THAT ACCOUNT
AND 50% WILL BE --
PUT INTO THE I. CAO WORKS THAT.
OKAY IN THIS IS WE'RE GOING TO
TALK ABOUT IT AT A LATER OF THE
TIME ALWAYS OF MY OTHER
QUESTIONS LATER THINKING.
THANK YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY OTHER.
QUESTIONS.
ON S. B. EIGHT FORTY THE BUDGET
BILL --
NOTHING ANYMORE QUESTIONS
ANYBODY WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT FORTY FOUR TO MAKE
SURE THE MIKE IS.
LIVE BACK THERE.
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION ON SB.
EIGHT FORTY OKAY SEEING NONE WE
WILL MOVE TO SB EIGHT FORTY ONE
SUPPLEMENTAL APPROPRIATIONS
TRAILER BILL.
THANK YOU THIS IS OUR
SUPPLEMENTAL APPROPRIATIONS BILL
FOR THE CURRENT YEAR TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND PROVIDES AN
AUGMENTATION OF EIGHT HUNDRED
AND NINETY POINT FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND TO ADDRESS AN
ANTICIPATED COST IN THE CURRENT
YEAR OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN NOTABLY EIGHT HUNDRED
THIRTY AYE POINT FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND.
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES FOR VARIOUS
UNANTICIPATED COSTS PRIMARILY
ATTRIBUTABLE TO INCREASE COSTS
IN THE MEDICAL PROGRAM DUE TO
NEW FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS
REGARDING DEFERRED CLAIMS.
AND DECREASED GENERAL FUND
OFFSETS FROM THE MANAGED CARE
ORGANIZATION TAX IN DRUG REBATES.
THE BILL ALSO INCLUDES FIFTY
NINE POINT NINE MILLION GENERAL
FUND TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION.
AND THE CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
HEALTH CARE SERVICES FRONT
UNANTICIPATED COSTS RESULTING
FROM THE HIGHER THAN PROJECTED
INMATE POPULATION AND WITHIN
THAT TOTAL OUR COST PER BADS
DENTAL MEDICAL SERVICES AS WELL
AS MENTAL HEALTH CARE.
AND THEN LASTLY THE BILL INCLUDE
SEVEN THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND
ELEVEN DOLLARS GENERAL FUND TO
REIMBURSE MARIPOSA COUNTY --
FOR HOMICIDE TRIAL COST THE
STATE COMPTROLLER'S OFFICE HAS
REVIEWED AND APPROVED THAT
REIMBURSEMENT CLAIM.
THANK YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
CANNOT SING ANY OTHER SUPPORT.
PUBLIC SUPPORT.
FOR S. B..
EIGHT FOUR ONE THAT'S AGAIN A
SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION S. B..
EIGHT FOUR ONE OKAY THANK YOU.
MOVING ON SP A FOR A HEART
TRANSPORTATION FROM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS BILL
PROVIDES FOR SOME NECESSARY
AMENDMENTS TO HELP FUND AND
STREAMLINE VARIOUS DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLE PROGRAMS AND
INCLUDES PROVISIONS TO HELP
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ADDRESS
VARIOUS TRANSPORTATION ISSUES.
THIS BILL ALLOWS UP FOR THE
STREAMLINING OF A PROGRAM THAT
GIVES ZERO OR LOW EMISSION
VEHICLES ACCESS TO COMMUTER
LANES.
CHANGES WOULD ALLOW DVD USE
IDENTIFICATION STICKERS MORE
EFFICIENTLY WITHOUT IMPACTING
THE PROGRAM THAT'S REDUCING I
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS BY ABOUT
ONE POINT TWO MILLION IN THE
BUDGET YEAR.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE BILL ALSO
AUTHORIZES THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL TO
ENTER INTO A LEASE PURCHASE
AGREEMENT FOR TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT.
BUILT TO SUIT CHP OFFICE
FACILITY TO REPLACE THEIR
EXISTING TRACY OFFICE.
THANK YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS ON S. B. EIGHT
FOUR EIGHT MISTER BELOW.
SO.
AMONGST THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
TRAILER BILL IS A ONE DOLLAR
INCREASE --
FOR FEES FOR THE I HAVE A
CONCERN ABOUT THAT BECAUSE WE
ARE GETTING LOTS OF COMPLAINTS
IN MY DISTRICT AND I THINK.
BUT DISTRICTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
THAT PEOPLE ARE HAVING TO WAIT
IN LONG LINES AT THE DMV.
BECAUSE OF WHAT THE PROBLEMS THE
REAL IDEA CAUSING AND AND THAT A
LACK OF AVAILABLE AYE PERSONNEL
THERE AND I KNOW THE DMV IS IS
WORKING ON THAT PROBLEM BUT IT
SEEMS COUNTERPRODUCTIVE TO BE
DIS INCENTIVIZING BEHAVIOR THAT
TAKES PEOPLE.
OUT OF THE DMV OFFICES AND GETS
THEIR PROBLEMS SOLVED IN THEIR
REGISTRATIONS RENEWED WITHOUT
HAVING TO GO TO THE DMV IS SO
I'M JUST WONDERING WHY --
IT MAKES SENSE TO INCREASE THE
FEE AND DIS INCENTIVIZE THAT
BEHAVIOR.
MARK BURNETT HEARD FINANCED
[inaudible]
I'M.
IN TERMS OF OUR PROPOSAL IS A
THREE YEAR SPEAKERS IN A THREE
YEAR.
ONE A ONE DOLLAR FEE INCREASE
AND M. CAN OF TO YOUR POINT --
THE OUR PROPOSAL NON IS TO NOT
TRANCE NOT TO MOVE THAT ON TO
INTO THE CUSTOMER SO THAT WE CAN
DIS INCENTIVIZING ACTION THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WOULDN'T.
TAKE PLACE --
RIGHT NOW --
WHEN -- A
SEED YOU GOING TOOK A DEALER HIT
BY A CAR --
THE IS THE DEALER WILL CHARGE
YOU -- IF
YOU WANNA GO TO REGISTER TO THE
DEALER THERE'S A FOUR DOLLAR FEE.
THAT -- THAT
YOU'LL PAY FOR THAT THE OF THE A
FIVE DOLLAR UP TO TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS CONVENIENCE FEE THAT CAN
BE PAID --
BUT IN TERMS OF THE ADDITIONAL
DOLLAR TO PAY FOR AN UPGRADE TO
A CALTRANS AYE TESIS --
HELD UNDER DMV'S --
MIGHTY SYSTEM --
THAT WOULD NOT GET PASSED ON TO
THE CUSTOMER.
OKAY THAT THAT'S DEFERRED
INFORMATION THAT I HAVE WHAT AT
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT.
THESE COMPANIES WOULD NOT PASS
THAT DOLLAR FEE INCREASE ON THE
CUSTOMER.
BECAUSE WE PUT IN THE TRAILER
BILL THAT THEY COULD NOT.
THEY CAN'T CHRIS SO BUT IF
YOU'RE IF YOU'RE.
INCREASING THEIR FEES ARCHER
JUSTIFIES DISINCENTIVE EYES IN
THEIR BEHAVIOR AND HELPING THE
DMV ALLEVIATE THIS CONGESTION
[inaudible]
WELL -- THEY
CURRENTLY HAVE THEY CAN CHARGE
IS TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS
CONVENIENCE FEE.
I'M TWO PEOPLE TO TO CUSTOMERS
BUYING CAR SO --
THIS WOULD POTENTIALLY THEN COME
OUT OF THAT WOULD BE A DOLLAR
LESS IF THEY WERE COLLECTED THAT
OR THAT THEY WOULD GET TO KEEP
FROM THAT FEE.
SO -- IF TO
THE EXTENT THAT THE ONE OF THE
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS.
DISINCENTIVE EYES IS THAT I
DON'T THINK THAT WOULD BE THE
CASE.
WHILE BOTH WERE TO CONTINUE THIS
DISCUSSION OFFLINE BUT I I HAVE
THIS A CONCERN I WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT WE DO AS MUCH AS WE CAN TO
GET CONGESTION OUT OF THE DIEM
THE OFFICES AND AND I CONCERNED
THAT THIS WAS GOING TO WORKING
AGAINST.
IN OPPOSITION TO THAT SO WE'LL
TALK ABOUT THAT OFFLINE THANK
YOU FRANCINE QUESTION.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
OKAY --
SUPPORT FOR S. B..
EIGHT FOUR EIGHT SEE NO SUPPORT
OPPOSITION HAS PAID FOR IT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MARK WHITE
AND ON BEHALF OF MOTOR VEHICLE
SOFTWARE CORPORATION.
WE ARE A AND ANY THAT IS
INVOLVED IN PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE DMV THE
VERY ENTITIES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE WAS
TALKING ABOUT WERE CALIFORNIA
BASED COMPANY ABOUT TUNER FIFTY
EMPLOYEES.
AND HERE'S WHAT WE DO WE GET
PEOPLE OUT OF LINE AT THE DMV
AND GET A MONO.
USING SOFTWARE USING INTERACTIVE
METHOD SO THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
TO SIT ONLINE AT DMV AND HAVE
ABOUT CUSTOMER EXPERIENCE.
ULTIMATELY EVERY TRANSACTION WE
GET OUT OF LINE A DMV FIELD
OFFICE AND WE GET ONLINE WE'RE
SAVING THE STATE ABOUT TWELVE
DOLLARS MAYBE MORE FOR EVERYONE
OF THOSE TRANSACTIONS.
THERE IS A SYSTEM THAT'S SET UP
TODAY THEY IS WORKING PROPERLY
AND THE SYSTEM THAT SET UP TODAY
IS.
WE ARE ALLOWED AS AS FINANCES
NOTED.
TO ASSESS A TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR
FEE THAT WE COLLECT FOR OUR
SERVICES THE COST OF OUR
SERVICES WHICH INCLUDES.
I'M NOT ONLY THE SOFTWARE
COMPONENT BUT MAILING OUT
LICENSE PLATES PROCESSING
STICKERS MILLION THE STICKERS
OUT STICKERS OUT EVERYTHING WE
DO ON BEHALF OF THE CUSTOMER.
WE CHARGE A TWENTY FIVE DOLLAR
FEE THAT FEE HAS BEEN TAPPED.
BY THE DMV FOR YEARS.
THAT HE'S NOT BEING RAISED.
SEPARATE FROM THAT THERE'S A
FOUR DOLLAR FEE THAT WE COLLECT
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE STATE.
WE REMITTANCE STATE TODAY.
SO THE PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU IN
THIS BUDGET TRAILER BILL WENT
OUT AN EXTRA DOLLAR.
ONTO THIS THE PART OF THE STATE
COLLECTS.
PROBLEM WITH IT IS IT DOESN'T
ALLOW US TO PASS IT THROUGH.
THAT'S A FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE FOR
US WE ESSENTIALLY ARE HAVING TO
PAY THIS EXTRA DOLLAR OUT OF OUR
OWN POCKETS WE CAN'T.
PASS IT THROUGH IN OUR PRODUCTS
AND SERVICES WHICH IS TYPICALLY
HOW A FEE WOULD WORK HE WOULD
PASS IT THROUGH AND PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES.
SO IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE IT DOES
EXACTLY WHAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OBERNOLTE TALK ABOUT IT AND
SENATE THIS INCENTIVIZE US FROM
DOING THESE PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE DMV.
ON IT IT IT'S GOING TO IMPACT
SERVICE AND IT'S GOING TO IMPACT
JOBS.
IN OUR COMMUNITIES THIS IS THE
TYPE OF THING WE THINK THERE'S
AN EASY FIX.
FOR WE THINK THERE'S A SOLUTION
HERE.
OUR TRIP THIS LIKE EVERY OTHER
FEE WE HAVE WITH THE DMV THAT
YOU'RE ALLOWED TO PASS THROUGH.
WE THINK ACTUALLY THERE COULD BE
A REGULATORY FIXED IN THIS.
AND IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT
NIGHT NEEDS TO BE INCLUDED AND
THIS PARTICULAR LANGUAGE WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TODAY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
THERE'S JOHN MOTH ON BEHALF OF
COMPUTERIZED VEHICLE
REGISTRATION JUST ONE ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE ON THIS
ISSUE WE ARE ANOTHER CALIFORNIA
BASED COMPANY WITH OFFICES IN
ORIGIN SANTA ROSA.
AND AND I I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THERE'S A CLEAR DISTINCTION HERE
AS TO WHO THE BENEFICIARY IS OF
THIS FEE.
IT'S NOT US.
THE BENEFICIARY OF THIS IS THE
CAR DEALER AND THE CAR BUYER
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE TO GO TO
THE DMV TO FILE THIS PAPERWORK.
DMV PUTS TOGETHER ITS COMPUTER
PROGRAMS WE PUT TOGETHER OUR
COMPUTER PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE THE
LINK BETWEEN THE DEALER AND THE
DMV TO MAKE THAT TRACK
TRANSACTION ELECTRONIC.
SO THE DMV IS GOING TO UPGRADE
ITS SYSTEM.
VIA THIS ONE DOLLAR FEE THAT
MEANS THERE IS AN ADDITIONAL
COST TO US NOT JUST BECAUSE THE
FEE BUT WE'VE GOT UPGRADE OUR
COMPUTER SYSTEM AS WELL.
SO THE ARGUE THAT WE ARE THE
BENEFICIARY OF THIS ADDITIONAL
DOLLAR IS NOT ACCURATE THE
ULTIMATE BENEFICIARY HERE IS THE
CONSUMER THEMSELVES GETTING OUT
A LINE AT THE DMV.
AND THE D. M. V. E. FOR YOU KNOW
IT HELPING TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONGESTION ISSUES IN THEIR
OFFICE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MARGARET
CAMPBELL ON BEHALF OF*
AUTOMOTIVE WE HAVE ONE OF OUR
MEMBER COMPANIES IS DEALER TRACK
WHICH IS LOCATED IN RANCHO
CORDOVA. FIVE HUNDRED POLICE
ALSO A FIRST LINE SERVICE
PROVIDER IN FOR ALL THE REASONS
STATED INCLUDING THIS IS ABOUT A
ONE AND A HALF TO TWO MILLION
DOLLAR HIT OUR COMPANY WE HAVE
OPPOSE THIS TRAILER BILL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THINGS
AFTERNOON MORE ABOUT IT WITH
TECH NET WE WANNA LINER COMES
WITH THOSE PREVIOUSLY STATED BY
THE OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
WE I ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH
UPDATING SOURCES OF THE DMV BUT
WE DON'T HAVE THE RIGHT WAY TO
GO ABOUT DOING IT YEAH
APPRECIATE YOUR KNOW ABOUT.
THANK YOU IDIOT OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEEN OTHER DISK WELL
INTERIOR MOVE ON I S. B..
EIGHT FIFTY THE HOUSING TRAILER
BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS
TRAILER BILL MAKES TECHNICAL
CLARIFICATIONS TO THE HOUSING
STREAMLINING STATUTE ENACTED IN
S. B. THIRTY FIVE LAST YEAR.
SPECIFICALLY THIS TRAILER BILL
CREATES THE HOMELESS EMERGENCY A
BLOCK GRANT PROGRAM AND
SPECIFIES HOW THE BUSINESS
CONSUMER SERVICES AND HOUSING
AGENCY WILL ADMINISTER THE FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
APPROPRIATION INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET.
PROGRAM PROVIDES FLEXIBLE FUNDS
FOR JURISDICTIONS THAT DECLARE
OUR LOCAL SHELTER CRISIS AND
DEMONSTRATE CITY COUNTY
COORDINATION --
THREE HUNDRED FIFTEEN MILLION
WILL BE ALLOCATED THROUGH
CONTINUUM'S OF CARE AND ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION WILL BE
ALLOCATED DIRECTLY TO CITIES
WITH POPULATIONS OVER THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND THE
TRAILER BILL ALSO ALLOCATES HALF
OF THE S. B. TO HOMELESSNESS
FUNDS TO THE HOUSING FOR A
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA PROGRAM.
AND HAVE TO AN AND MENDED
EMERGENCY SOLUTIONS GRANT
PROGRAM.
THE TRAILER BILL ALSO MOVES THE
HOMELESS COORDINATING AND
FINANCING COUNSEL TO THE
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES AND
HOUSING AGENCY.
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
IN THE COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS MS
COMPANY ARE.
SO I I THINK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT ARM. FOR THE RECITATION OF
THE OF THE BIG BIG DOLLARS THE
HARD PART FOR ME AND AND WITH A
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME THAT WE'VE
HAD TO KINDA LOOK AT THIS.
IS TO FIGURE OUT FRANKLY WHETHER
ANY MONEY IS GOING TO GO TO
RURAL CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE A LOT OF IT IS WAITED
VERY HEAVILY TOWARDS THE BIG
CITIES [inaudible]
SO -- AND IN
THAT CONCERNS ME BECAUSE RURAL
CALIFORNIA HAS.
YEAH AS SIGNIFICANT A HOUSING
PROBLEM AS THE BIG CITIES NUMBER
ONE AND NUMBER TWO THE AGE TO
PROGRAM AS COMMAND AND HAS
REALLY DRIVEN FAMILIES OUT OF
THAT THERE.
THE HOUSING THAT THEY WOULD HAVE
NORMALLY BEEN IN INTO SEVERELY
OVERCROWDED HOUSING AND SO MANY
OF THEM ARE NOW FINDING
THEMSELVES OUT ON THE STREETS AS
WELL AND SO ON I'M I'M REALLY
CONCERNED I I I'M I'M HAPPY WITH
HOW THIS IS BEEN ORGANIZED
EXCEPT FOR THAT.
THE THE WAY THAT IT'S BEEN
ORGANIZED TO FOCUS ON HOMELESS
POINT IN TIME COUNTS OF VERY
HIGH NUMBERS I'M JUST NOT SURE
THAT ANY OF THE MONEY'S GOING TO
GET TO RECOVERING MAYBE CAN.
ABSOLUTELY A KING THAT THAT'S A
FAIR CONCERN I WOULD SAY THAT
THERE ARE THREE DIFFERENT
ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY IS
INCLUDED IN THIS TRAILER BILL TO
GET TO THAT CONCERN.
SO THIS BUILDS UP THE
ADMINISTRATION'S MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL WHICH PROPOSED A
BLENDED APPROACH IT LOOKS AT
POINT IN TIME BUT IT ALSO
CREATES BANDS.
SO THAT THERE'S NOT HUGE CLIFFS
IN THE GRANT AMOUNTS BETWEEN
INDIVIDUALS WE DON'T ONLY USE
POINT IN TIME COUNT.
ON THE NEXT --
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
RESPECTIVELY I'M ARE FOR CITIES
ON AND THEY'RE DIRECTLY
APPROPRIATES THE LARGEST CITIES
BASED ON POPULATION AND AND
THERE IS ONE POT THAT IS
SPECIFICALLY BASED IN POINT IN
TIME BUT BETWEEN THE TWO
METHODOLOGIES THEY THINK THAT
WE'VE STOCK WE'VE GOT GOOD.
COVERAGE TO ADDRESS YOUR ISSUE
I'D ALSO NOTE THAT THERE IS A
WAIVER ALLOWED ON AND WE
SPECIFICALLY INCLUDED IT FOR
RULE COMMUNITIES.
ON IN WHICH DECLARING A SHELTER
EMERGENCY MAY NOT REALLY BE --
REASONABLE FOR THEM ALMOND.
OAKLEY FOR RURAL AREAS OF THE
CITY.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY SEEING NONE I HAVE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY SUPPORT.
GEN FREER AND SUPPORT I HAVE THE
TRAILER BILL AROUND HOUSING AND
FOR YOUR INCLUSION AND ATTENTION
TO YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND SETTING A FLOOR
OF AT LEAST 5% OF THE FUND'S
BEEN DEDICATED TOWARDS A YEAR.
SO ONE OF THAT THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND HOPE THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO DO MORE FOR YOU
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THEY TEND
TO BE MESSED ON THAT AND THE
CONVERSATION AROUND HOMELESSNESS
BECAUSE A LOT OF THE FOCUS IS ON
THE CHRONIC.
WHERE WE DO YOU ALSO KNOW THAT
50% THE CHRONIC ADULTS
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS WHEN
THEY WERE YOU BETWEEN EIGHTEEN
TO TWENTY FOUR SOMEONE ENSURE
THAT WE ARE PAYING SPECIAL
ATTENTION TO THAT YOU POPULATION?
AND THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH
US.
YOU'D BE ALSO SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
FROM THE PUBLIC.
OKAY SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT ITEM.
S. B. EIGHT FIVE ONE FIRST
GENERAL GOVERNMENT TRAILER BILL.
THANK YOU THIS TRAILER BILL
CREEK THE STATE'S
SUPPLEMENTATION FOR COUNTY
ASSESSOR'S PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES TO COUNTY ASSESSORS TO
HIRE NEW STAFF IMPROVE IT
SYSTEMS AND MORE ACCURATELY
VALUE.
NEW AND EXISTING PROPERTY THE
BILL MAKES TECHNICAL CHANGES TO
THE TRANSFER OF THREE PROPERTY
TAX PROGRAMS FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF TAX AND FEE ADMINISTRATION.
TO THE BOARD OF EQUALIZATION THE
BOARD OF EQUALIZATION CURRENTLY
ADMINISTERS THESE PROGRAMS FOR
ICD TFA UNDER AN INTER AGENCY
AGREEMENT.
THE BILL CHANGES THE NAME OF THE
SECURE CHOICE RETIREMENT SAVIGS
PROGRAM TO THE CALCIUM VERS
RETIREMENT SAVINGS PROGRAM WHICH
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE ACTIONS
OF THAT BOARD.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
OKAY ANY SUPPORT FOR S. B..
EIGHT FIVE ONE SEEING NONE --
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
OPPOSED TO S. B..
EIGHT FIVE ONE MOVE FORWARD S.
B.. EIGHT FIVE TWO AM BEFORE
THAT WE WILL TAKE ROLE.
TING HERE.
OBERNOLTE HERE ARAMBULA
[inaudible]
BLUE [inaudible]
BROKE [inaudible]
CAREER [inaudible]
TRAVIS [inaudible]
CHIU.
CHOI HERE COOPER [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
HARPER JUST SAWYER.
KILEY.
LACKEY HERE AMONG [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WHAT [inaudible]
HOMES [inaudible]
FOR THANK YOU [inaudible]
ACOSTA BE.
EIGHT FIVE TWO I THINK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THIS BILL RATIFIES
THE UNION CONTRACT BETWEEN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFERS ASSOCIATION THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL DO NOT
TAKE EFFECT UNLESS THE FUNDS ARE
SPECIFICALLY APPROPRIATED BY THE
LEGISLATURE.
THE COLLECTIVELY BARGAINED
CONTRACT WITH CCPOA RESULTS IN
BUDGET YOUR COST TOTALING ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE MILLION.
OF WHICH ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
TWO MILLION OR GENERAL FUND FOR
CCPOA MEMBERS AND RELATED
EXCLUDED EMPLOYEES.
THESE OUR INCLUDED AND THAT
BUDGET ITEM.
NINETY EIGHT HUNDRED THESE COSTS
ARE THE RESULT OF PERMITTING
CCPOA MEMBERS TO CASH OUT UP TO
EIGHTY HOURS OF COMPENSABLE
LEAVE PROVIDING THE LATEST
EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTION FOR HEALTH
CARE PREMIUM RATES.
INCREASING THE ANNUAL UNIFORM
ALLOWANCE AND INCREASING THE
NIGHT SHIFT AND WE CAN PAY
DIFFERENTIALS.
WITH THE 5% GENERAL SALARY
INCREASE BEGINNING AND TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TOTAL BUDGETARY
COSTS OVER THE DURATION OF THE
ONE YEAR CONTRACT WILL BE A
PROPS APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE MILLION.
OF WHICH FOUR HUNDRED FIFTEEN
MILLION IS CHEN WE WOULD KNOW
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS SOUGHT
SYSTEMIC IMPROVEMENTS LIKE
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
CORRECTIONAL COUNSELORS. TO
REDUCE CASELOADS OF THAT THEY
COULD SPEND MORE TIME WITH
INMATES.
SEARCHING UP PRISONS TSA STYLE
WHICH THE UNION DOES HAVE THE
RIGHT TO BARGAIN ABOUT AND
ALTHOUGH THESE ARE NOT CONTRACT
SPECIFIC WE DO ACKNOWLEDGE THEM
AS OUR PARTNERS.
AND IT WILL BE DAY NOT US ALONE
WHO WILL CREATE BETTER PATHWAYS
FOR OFFENDERS TO GET OUT AND NOT
COME BACK INTO OUR PRISON SYSTEM.
WE WANT THE MOST PROFESSIONAL
WORKFORCE WE CAN GET AND WE
RECOGNIZE THE DIFFICULT AND
OFTEN DANGEROUS JOBS THAT THIS
BARGAINING UNIT DO [inaudible]
THANK YOU ASTRONAUT.
I'M A BIG SUPPORTER OF THE WORK
THAT OUR CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS DO AND I VOTED FOR
THESE ARE WILL USE IN THE PAST
BUT I'M STRUGGLING WITH THIS.
ONE THIS IS A ONE YEAR M. O. U.
WITH A 5% PAY INCREASE.
IN AN ERA WHEN INFLATION IS
RUNNING UNDER 3% OF CALIFORNIA'S
OR WERE INFLATION IT WERE
INCREASING COMPENSATION BY
ALMOST TWICE THE RATE OF
INFLATION WAS THE JUSTIFICATION
FOR THAT.
ALL THE FOR AND I HAD TO OUR
DIRECTOR OF KELLY DRIVE BUT I
WOULD NOTE THAT IT IS IN LINE
WITH SOME OF THE OTHER GS SIZE
THAT WE'VE PROVIDED TO OTHER
BARGAINING UNITS.
NOTABLY BARGAINING UNIT TWO
ATTORNEYS BARGAINING UNIT NINE
ENGINEERS AND BARGAINING UNIT
TEN SCIENTISTS THEY ALL RECEIVED
5% YES SIZEAS PART OF THEIR
CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS AS WELL.
THANK YOU RICHARD YOU'LL HAVE
DIRECTOR OF COLLEGE ARE --
WHAT WE BELIEVE THIS IS A FAIR
CONTRACT THAT IF YOU LOOK AT
PRIOR CONTRACTS WITH THIS UNION
THEY -- YOU
KNOW THEY THEY GOT A NET OF 5%
OVER. THREE YEARS AND THE LAST
CONTRACT SO IF YOU LOOK AT THE
MAP RESPECTIVE THEY WERE
TRAILING --
CPI THIS FAR AS THEIR SALARIES
KEEPING UP WITH INFLATION SO WE
THINK IN THE END.
WE THINK THIS IS A FAIR CONTRACT
WE THINK IT REFLECTS THE PARTIES
THE GOVERNOR TO FOCUS ON REAL
BILL REHABILITATIVE SERVICES.
AND I HELPING INMATES GET OUT
ONLY PRODUCTIVELY LIVES A
RECOGNIZES THE CRITICAL WORK IN
THE DANGEROUS ENVIRONMENT THAT
ARE CRACKS OFFICERS FACE
EVERYDAY PROTECTING.
CALIFORNIANS AND ALSO THE
INMATES IN THE CUSTODY
[inaudible]
WELL I OBVIOUSLY ALSO SUPPORT
THAT WORK BUT I'M ALSO FOCUSED
ON THE FACT THAT.
THE COST OF INCARCERATING A
PRISONER IN CALIFORNIA ARE THE
HIGHEST IN THE COUNTRY AND THIS
IS ONE OF THE REASONS AND THAT'S
WHY I THINK IT'S JUST DIFFICULT
TO JUSTIFY THAT SIZE OF A SALARY
INCREASE.
THANK YOU.
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC A
SUPPORT.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
OPPOSED.
OKAY SAYING NO WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO SB EIGHT FIVE THREE
DEVELOPMENT HOLE DEVELOPMENT
[inaudible]
SERVICES TRUMP.
THIS COST THANK YOU THIS IS OUR
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES ON THE
BUS KILL THE BILL LARGELY
CODIFIES PRACTICES CURRENTLY
FOLLOWED BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND
CLARIFY CERTAIN CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AND POLICIES
FOLLOWED BY THE DEPARTMENT AND
OUR REGIONAL CENTERS.
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL PROVIDES
THE DEPARTMENT FLEXIBILITY TO
CONTINUOUSLY OPERATE CERTAIN
CRISIS FACILITIES PROVIDES FOR
BROAD STAKEHOLDER INPUT AND
SETTING PRIORITIES FOR THE SELF
DETERMINATION PROGRAM.
EXPANDS ACCESS TO RECORDS FOR
CONSUMER REPRESENTATIVES
REQUIRES THE PUBLISHING OF REST
MY POLICY ASSESSMENT TOOLS AND
CLEARLY DEFINES THE ASSESSMENT
PROCESS FOR ADMISSION TO THE
PORTERVILLE SECURE TREATMENT
EIGHT AREA.
THANK YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE THE SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THE OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AMBER'S JORDAN'S WITH THE ARCTIC
CALIFORNIA --
SIMPLY WANT TO STATE THAT DID
THE BONTA DISABILITY COMMUNITY
WAS VERY DISAPPOINTED WITH THE
OUTCOMES OF THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE ESPECIALLY CONSIDERING
THAT WITH THE SURPLUS THAT WE
HAVE IN THE STATE THE STATE IS
AND CUTS IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINE STILL REMAIN
AND ALTHOUGH WE THOSE DID PASS
THE SENT BOTH ASSEMBLY AND
SENATE SUBCOMMITTEES --
THEY WERE IN.
PULLED BACK IN A CONFERENCE AND
THEN WE'RE NOT PASSED AT A
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE --
SO VERY DISAPPOINTED IN THOSE
OUTCOMES.
I CAN EITHER OPPOSITION.
WILL MOVE BEFORE TO SB EIGHT
FIVE FOR THE RESOURCES TRAILER
BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS
TRAILER BILL INCLUDES MULTIPLE
ISSUES THAT SUPPORT THE
PRESERVATION OF NATURAL CULTURAL
RESOURCES ENHANCE THE STATE'S
RECYCLING PROGRAM PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL TRANSPARENCY THROUGH
REPORTING TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GENERAL PUBLIC PUBLIC.
AND MAKE TECHNICAL CLEANUP AT
CHANGES NECESSARY TO EFFECTUATE
IMPLEMENTED CURRENT LAW.
WE'VE KNOWN IN THIS TRAILER BILL
I'M WITH LONG DISCUSS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
STRUCTURAL A BUDGET IN BALANCE
AND THE TRAILER BILL WILL
INITIATE A SERVICE BASED PROP
BUDGET REVIEW AND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A TRACKING SYSTEM
TO SUPPORT.
AN ANALYSIS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE'S EXISTING
PROGRAM ACTIVITIES AND REVENUE
SHARING.
THE BUDGET BILL PROVIDES THREE
YEARS OF FUNDING FOR THE
DEPARTMENT WHILE WE ENGAGE IN
THIS A SERVICE BASED REVIEW.
THANK YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
MISTER WHAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF
MISTRUST OF THE BUT WE'VE HAD
THIS DISCUSSION BEFORE BUT IT'S
ALWAYS A CHALLENGE TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S BUDGETARY.
WHEN WE'RE DRAFTING A BUDGET
TRAILER BILL AND RELATED?
AND I THINK MOST OF US IN THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD PREFER THAT
THE POLICY GETS KEPT OUT OF THE
BUDGET.
AND DECIDED IN POLICY WHEN --
WHEN WE'RE DEBATING THINGS AND
POLICY COMMITTEE?
OTHERS.
IN THIS BILL I THINK IT KIND OF
A LOT OF THINGS THAT.
SEEM TO BE PRETTY CLEARLY POLICY
AND NOT BUDGET I JUST A FEW OF
THEM AND YOU MENTION OF SOME OF
THEM THE WILD SCENIC AND
RECREATIONAL RIVER DESIGNATION
SUPPLEMENT BIGELOW HAD A BILL ON
THAT.
THE A REAUTHORIZATION OF THE THE
PLASTIC --
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM ASSEMBLYMAN
BERMAN HEADED.
BILL ON THAT THE THE S. B. FIFTY
CLEAN UP ASSEMBLYMAN GRAYSON HAD
A BILL ON THAT SO I'M JUST
WONDERING WHAT WAS A
JUSTIFICATION FOR PUTTING THOSE
THINGS IN A BUDGET TRAILER BILL
INSTEAD OF LETTING THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS WORKS.
THE WAY IT WAS INTENDED.
TO MALL OF ONE OF THE EXAMPLES
THAT YOU CITED THE PLASTIC
MARKET DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM WAS
ACTUALLY ADMINISTRATIVE A
PROPOSAL THAT WAS INCLUDED ARMY
REVISION.
OKAY THAT'S GOV UNSATISFYING TO
SAY -- IT'S
IT'S BUDGETARY BECAUSE WE PUT AT
THE MIRROR REVISION RIGHT.
THERE'S ALSO AN ASSOCIATE A
PREPARATION A FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THAT PARTICULAR
PROGRAM AND I WOULD NOTE THAT
MANY OF THE EXAMPLES YOU'VE
PROVIDED THERE'S A COMMENSURATE
DOLLAR AMOUNT ASSOCIATEDWITH
THEM.
OKAY WELL OF IT WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO DISAGREE ON THIS
OBVIOUSLY BUT I I WOULD JUST FOR
THE RECORD LIKE TO SAY THAT I
PREFER.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE DEBATE
POLICY RELATED BILLS IN POLICY
COMMITTEE AND NOT THROUGH THE
BUDGET.
THANK YOU MANY OF THE COMMENTS.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
SUPPORT.
ANY MEMBERS OF PUBLIC OPPOSED.
OKAY MOVING ON TO SB EIGHT FIVE
FIVE THE TAX TRAILER BILL.
THANK YOU THIS PARTICULAR
TRAILER BILL CONTAINS THREE I
DIFFER PROVISIONS THE BILL
EXPANDS THE EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT BEGINNING WITH TAX YEAR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO WORKING
INDIVIDUALS WITHOUT DEPENDENTS
WHO ARE AGE EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
FOUR ARE OVER THE AGE OF SIXTY
FIVE AND INCREASES THE
QUALIFYING INCOME RANGE TO
INCLUDE.
EMPLOYEES WORKING FULL TIME AT
THE TWENTY NINETEEN MINIMUM WAGE
OF TWELVE DOLLARS PER HOUR.
WE ARE PROJECTING THAT THE
EXPANSION WILL COST SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND WILL BENEFIT OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
HOUSEHOLDS IN THE STATE.
THIS BILL ALSO EXTENDS THE NEW
EMPLOYEE CREDIT WHICH WAS DUE TO
EXPIRE FOR HIGHER IS MADE ON OR
AFTER JULY ONE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
FOR FIVE YEARS.
WHICH WILL CONTINUE TO ENCOURAGE
THE HIRING OF HARD TO HIRE
INDIVIDUALS AT MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED AND 50% OF THE STATE
MINIMUM WAGE.
THIS BILL ALSO EXTENDS THE
CALIFORNIA COMPETES TAX CREDIT
ALLOCATIONS AT ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY MILLION A ANNUALLY FROM
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
TELL TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
ELIMINATE THE REQUIREMENT.
THAT SMALL BUSINESSES RECEIVE
25% OF THE TOTAL ALLOCATIONS
ALTHOUGH SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
STILL ELIGIBLE FOR A CREDIT
ALLOCATION.
THANK YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
SCENE NUMBER GOING TO MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT GENERAL GOVERNMENT
TRAILER BILL S. B. EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT DEALING WITH.
VOTING SYSTEMS AND VETERANS MISS
COST.
I THINK YOU OF THIS TRAILER BILL
INCLUDES LANGUAGE THAT GUIDES
THE ALLOCATION OF THE ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLAR GENERAL
FUND --
INVESTMENT RELATED TO
REPLACEMENT OF COUNTY VOTING
SYSTEMS AND THE ASSOCIATED
ACTIVITIES STATEWIDE.
I SPECIFICALLY THE LANGUAGE
REQUIRES THE SECRETARY OF STATE
TO USE THE FUNDS APPROPRIATED TO
REIMBURSE COUNTIES FOR FUNDS
SPENT ON REPLACEMENT LEASE OR
DEVELOPMENT OF VOTING EQUIPMENT.
THIS BILL REQUIRES ALSO THAT THE
CALIFORNIA VICTIM COMPENSATION
BOARD CONSIDER WHETHER THE
VICTIM OR DERIVATIVE VICTIMS
INCURRED EMOTIONAL HARM OR LOSS
AS A RESULT OF THE RECENT
IDENTIFICATION AT THE EAST AREA
RAPISTS OR GOLDEN STATE KILLER.
WHEN CONSIDERING WHETHER TO
GRANT A TIME EXTENSION FOR
VICTIM COMPENSATION PAYMENTS?
THIS TRAILER BILL ALSO INCLUDES
LANGUAGE THAT MODIFIES EXISTING
REQUIREMENTS PURSUANT TO THE
CURRENT YEAR TWENTY SEVENTEEN
BUDGET ACT FOR THE CAL THAT
MASTER PLAN FOR THE OVERALL
OPERATIONS VETERANS HOMES.
THANK YOU ANY.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE ANY.
PUBLIC COMMENT TO SUPPORT.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEE NOW WE ARE MOVING TO
THE SP EIGHT FIVE NINE PROP
NINETY EIGHT CERTIFICATION
DISCUSSED.
I THINK IT THIS IS AN EDUCATION
TRAILER BILL THAT DEALS
SPECIFICALLY WITH THE
CERTIFICATION OF THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE.
IT CREATES A NEW ANNUAL PROCESS
FOR CERTIFYING THAT PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT MINIMUM GUARANTEE.
DESIGNATED TO STREAMLINE THE
CERTIFICATION PROCESS ALLOW FOR
GREATER TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCURACY IN THAT CALCULATION AND
IT ENSURES PROMPT PAYMENT OF
OUTSTANDING SETTLE UP.
AND CREATES A MECHANISM TO
RESOLVE DISPARITIES IN A
REASONABLE TIMEFRAME.
THE BILL ALSO CREATES --
A CONTINUES A PREPARATION FOR
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT.
IN IT REQUIRES THE CERTIFICATION
OF THE PROP.
SCHOOL YEARS TWENTY NINE TEN
THROUGH SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN AND
ANNUALLY BEGINNING IN.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN THANK YOU
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
ANY.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
OKAY STING NINE ANY BODY IN
SUPPORT.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC POST.
SEEING NONE WERE MOVING ON TO S.
B. EIGHT SIXTEEN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TRAILER BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS BILL
CREATES THE STATUTORY STRUCTURE
FOR REPLACING THE CAPITAL ANNEX
AND FOR A NEW OFFICE BUILDING
THAT WILL INITIALLY SERVE.
AS SWING SPACE FOR THE ANNEX
DURING ITS CONSTRUCTION.
IT EXPANDS THE EXISTING PROJECT
AUTHORITY TO INCLUDE ANCILLARY
IMPROVEMENTS WHICH MAY INCLUDE A
VISITORS CENTER HE RELOCATED OR
EXPANDED UNDERGROUND PARKING
FACILITY AND ANY NEEDED
DECONSTRUCTION IN INFRASTRUCTURE
WORK.
WITHOUT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE.
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
BOB I THINK WE ALL ARE UNANIMOUS
ARE PINION AT THE ANNEX NEEDS
SOME SERIOUS ATTENTION I'M
CURIOUS WHAT WAS THE AGE
JUSTIFICATION FOR EXEMPTING THE
ANNEX REPLACEMENT PROJECT FROM
STATE CONTRACTING LAW.
HOW CHRIS LEAVE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE --
THE IT'S ESSENTIALLY TO ALLOW
ANY DELIVERY METHOD TO BE USED
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE
ANNEX THAT'S AGREED UPON BETWEEN
JOINT ROLES.
AND THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
SO THAT THIS ALLOWS THE EXPLODED.
EXPEDITED --
PURSUING THE PROJECT BOOK OKAY I
MEAN I KNOW WHAT IT DOES --
BUT WEEK WE QUITE OFTEN.
FLEXIBILITY OF GETTING AROUND
STATE CONTRACTING LAW AND THEY
HAVE THE SAME JUSTIFICATIONS FOR
WANTING.
TO SO TO USE THAT FLEXIBILITY
SOME JUST WONDERING WHY.
THEY KNOW WHY WE'RE EXEMPTING
OURSELVES FROM THAT WHEN WE
DON'T ACCEPT OTHERS.
IT WAS TO ALLOW THAT THE PROJECT
TO USE ALTERNATIVE TO DELIVERY
METHODS THAT --
AREN'T FUNDED.
OKAY I IN I JUST [inaudible]
BUT I WOULD REPLACE THE ANNEX TO
I JUST THINK WHAT'S GOOD FOR THE
GOOSE SHOULD BE GOOD FOR THE
GANDER HERE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OF SB.
EIGHT SIXTY HEY BUDDY OPPOSE S.
B. IT'S OKAY THING DONE WE ARE
MOVING TO A S. B. --
EIGHT SIX FOUR RESERVE ACCOUNTS
AND FONG CAN ASK IS.
DURING THIS TIME.
IS THIS IS THE ITEM THAT I
REFERENCE TO MY EARLIER
TESTIMONY AT THIS BILL IT'S
CONSISTENT WITH THE OVERALL
BUDGET FRAMEWORK IN WHICH I'M WE
FULLY FUNDED AND THE STATE'S I
HAVE BUDGET STABILIZATION
ACCOUNT UNDER PROPOSITION.
TWO THE BILL CREATES TWO NEW
RESERVE FUNDS FOR THE STATE IT
CREATES THE BUDGET DEFICIT
SAVINGS ACCOUNT.
AS WELL AS THE SAFETY NET
RESERVE FUND WHICH HAS TO SUB
ACCOUNTS WITHIN IT AYE FOR MEDI
CAL AND CAL WORKS.
FIRST OUR START WITH THE BUDGET
DEFICIT SAVINGS ACCOUNT WHICH
WILL TEMPORARILY HOLD THE
SUPPLEMENTAL DEPOSIT TO THE
BUDGET STABILIZATION ACT.
UPON UPDATE THROUGH THE NINETEEN
TWENTY MAY REVISE PROCESS THE
AMOUNT OF THE SUPPLEMENTAL
DEPOSIT WILL BE TRANSFERRED INTO
THE BUDGET DEFICIT SAVINGS
ACCOUNT FROM THE BUDGET DEFICIT
SAVINGS ACCOUNT EXCUSE ME TO THE
BSA.
IF THERE IS ANY REMAINING AMOUNT --
AFTER THAT TRANSFER 50% OF THAT
WILL BE TRANSFERRED TO THE NEW
SAFETY NET RESERVE AND THE OTHER
50% WILL STAY IN THIS NEW
ACCOUNT.
ARE THE BILL ALSO TRANSFERS TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO THE SAFETY NET
RESERVE FUND SPECIFICALLY INTO
THE COW WORK SUB ACCOUNT WITHOUT
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS TRUMP YEAH --
THEY APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN --
IF THE COULD YOU PROVIDE ME SOME
HISTORICAL CONTEXT OR HIS HAS AT
THAT HISTORICAL BACKGROUND IN
TERMS OF THE SP <c.green> YOU IN</c>
TERMS OF WHY WAS CREATED AND THE
PROVISION THAT SAYS THAT --
A SALES TAX CUT WOULD BE KICKING
IN IF WE DID WE FEEL THAT.
ALL DEFERRED MY COLLEAGUE ON THE
HISTORY BUT THERE ARE CODE
SECTIONS THAT ALLOW FOR EACH
TRIGGER MECHANISM BASICALLY IF
THE BALANCE OF THE FFT YOU
REACHES A CERTAIN THRESHOLD.
ON THAT WOULD GENERATE A SALES
TAX A TEMPORARY SALES TAX
DECREASE.
THANK YOU CREDIT BECAUSE THE
OTHER DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AND I'M NOT SURE ON HOW MUCH OF
THE HISTORY YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
ON THE RESERVES BUT IN GENERAL
THE THIS SFU IS MORE OF THE HAVE
ACCESS.
TO THAT LATER ON IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN VOTERS APPROVED THE
MORE RESTRICTIVE PROPOSITION TWO
RESERVES.
SO WHY WAS THAT WHY WAS THAT
THAT THE SALES TAX CUT PROVISION
INCLUDED WHAT WHAT WAS THE
PURPOSE BEHIND IT.
I KNOW IF I TELL YOU ON THAT.
YOU TO GET BACK TOGETHER YES --
SO JUST OF OF FROM A DRUM A
GENERAL PUBLIC STAMP WHAT I I
GUESS THAT WOULD BE THE REASON
WHY I'M ASKING THIS I DON'T
THINK THE GENERAL PUBLIC
UNDERSTANDS THAT.
IF WE DO HAVE ADDITIONAL SAVINGS
THAT AS AS WE FILL THESE --
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS THAT THERE IS A
TRIGGER MECHANISM THAT ALLOWS
FOR THE MONEY TO GO BACK --
AND TO THE TO THE ECONOMY OR TO
THE TO THE GENERAL POPULATION TO
ASSAIL SEX REPRODUCTION IS THAT
CORRECT.
THAT'S CORRECT AND THE
CONFERENCE BUDGET BEFORE YOU
DOES NOT HAVE IT WOULD NOT
TRIGGER THAT MECHANISM.
AND IS THAT IT IN IS THAT
BECAUSE WE CREATE A THIRD
ACCOUNT.
NO IT'S MORE BECAUSE OF THE
EXPENDITURE PLAN.
SO WHEN THAT WAS THERE A
DISCUSSION THEN IN IN IN
DETERMINING WHETHER TO CREATE
ADDITIONAL COUNTS VERSUS JUST
PUTTING ALL THE MONEY INTO.
A EXISTING SAVINGS ACCOUNTS.
BOTH OF THE RESERVE FUNDS BEFORE
YOU WERE AND BROUGHT THE FORCES
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS SO THE
SAFETY RESERVE ACCOUNT WITH US
SENATE PROPOSAL.
ON AND THE BUDGET DEFICIT
SAVINGS ACCOUNT WASN'T ASSEMBLY
PROPOSAL I THINK TO GO BACK TO
MY COLLEAGUES FURTHER POINT.
ON IT'S THE BALANCE IN THE SFE
YOU THAT TRIGGERS THE SALES TAX
ON BUT THERE'S A COUPLE THINGS
HAPPENING HERE NOT THE LEAST OF
WHICH IS THAT THE EXPENDITURE
AMOUNT WOULDN'T ALLOW FOR THAT
SUGAR TO BE REACHED IN THE ASSET
FEE YOU BASED ON SPENDING THAT'S
INCLUDED.
AND GUN JUST AND WHAT IS THE
TRICK WHAT WHAT WHAT POINT WITH
THE TRIGGER OCCUR.
OTHER SO THERE'S TWO DIFFERENT
TRIGGERS THE FIRST IS IF THE
BALANCE REACHES GREATER THAN 4%
OF GENERAL FUND REVENUES IN BOTH
THE PRIOR YEAR AND THE CURRENT
YEAR.
SO THAT WOULD BE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
THEN THE SECOND TRIGGER IS IF
THE BALANCE AND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN REACHES 3% OF GENERAL
FUND REVENUES WHICH IS ABOUT
FOUR POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS.
AND ALSO THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S OUT FORECAST
FOR REVENUES INCREASES BETWEEN
MAY THIRTIETH AND SEPTEMBER
FIRST.
I BELIEVE IT'S SEPTEMBER FIRST
BUT IT'S MAY THIRTIETH AND
ANOTHER POINT IN SEPTEMBER --
IN IN THE CURRENT YEAR.
SO BOTH OF THOSE TRIGGERS WOULD
HAVE THE CAR* FOR TAT FOR
THOSE BONUS FOR TWO AT THE MET.
SO WITHIN EACH OF THOSE TRIGGERS
BOTH CRITERIA HAVE TO BE MAD
RIGHT SO BUT BUT EITHER ONE
COULD BE TRIGGERED SO FEW IN THE
FIRST CASE HIT 4% IN BOTH
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND THAT ONE WHAT
HAPPENED.
AND IN THE SECOND CASE IF YOU
HAD THAT SITUATION WHERE THE
FORECAST INCREASES AND ALSO YOU
HIT 3% AND EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THE
NOT TRIGGER WHAT. TO WHAT WHAT
THE LEVEL BE FOR THE FIRST
PRETTY I POLICY YOU IS THAT I
DON'T WANT FOUR POINT ONE
BILLION. FOR GOD THIS IT'S IT'S
ROUGHLY FOUR POINT WAS TO THE
FOUR POINT ONE MILLION IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IS.
FOR THE SECOND TRIGGER THE 4%
HIGHER IT'S IT'S ABOUT FIVE
BILLION IN EACH YEAR ALTHOUGH I
DON'T HAVE THAT NUMBER OFF THE
TOP OF MY HEAD BUT THAT ONE IS A
LOT HIGHER SO THE STATE IS NOT
REALLY AT RISK OF HITTING ON ONE
OF THE ONE THAT MIGHT.
BE YOU KNOW CLOSER TO OF ISSUE
IS -- IS THE
SECOND TRIGGER WITH A 3%.
AND JUST MY LAST QUESTION IS WAS
THERE EVER DISCUSSION OF USING
MORE MONEY ABUSING IS THAT MORE
PUTTING MORE THE MONEY INTO THE
EXISTING TWO ACCOUNTS --
INSTEAD OF TREATING THE THIRD
ACCOUNT.
WE'VE REACH THE CONSTITUTIONAL
TARGET AND THE PROP TO RESERVE
AMOUNT CELL AND MORE AT THE
HIGHEST THAT IT CAN GO SO WHAT
HAPPENS IF YOU CONTINUE TO PUT
IT.
UP WELL ACTUALLY AND THERE'S
ANOTHER ITEM THAT WILL GET TO
UNDER THE PROVISIONS OF PROP TWO
ONCE YOU REACH THE
CONSTITUTIONAL TARGET OF 10%.
ANYTHING ABOVE AND BEYOND THAT
SPILLS OVER IT'S REQUIRED FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO IF WE HAD PUT MORE MONEY INTO
THE PROP TWO ABOVE AND BEYOND
THE MONEY WE COULD
INFRASTRUCTURE.
IT'S A LITTLE MORE COMPLICATED
BUT IT'S EVIDENCE WHATSOEVER
LET'S LET THE REQUIRED AMOUNT SO
WE THE NEXT NEXT YEAR WHEN YOU.
PUT ANOTHER WAY WHAT IT WOULD BE
USED AFTER SESSION THE FOLLOWING
YEAR CRACKS ABOUT IT IN IN NEXT
YEAR'S BUDGET SINCE WE'RE
PROPOSE THAT.
SINCE WE BE AT 10% ANY
ADDITIONAL REQUIRED CALCULATION
FOR POP TO THE BALANCE YOU DON'T
NEED 410% GOES TO INTEREST.
OKAY SO SO I THINK WE'RE SAYING
THE SAME THING IT DOES NOT
INFRASTRUCTURE JUST DOESN'T GO
THIS YEAR GOES NEXT YEAR GREAT
THANK YOU.
AND AND ALEJO DITTO IF YOU
WANTED A OR COULD ANSWER MR
FUNG'S FIRST QUESTION AROUND
SOME OF THE HISTORY OF THE YES
OF THE FIRST SALES TAX SUGAR WAS
PASSED AS PART OF THE NINETEEN
NINETY NINETY ONE ON BUDGET.
AND THE SECOND ONE WAS PER THE
TWO THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND ONE
BUDGET -- IN
THE NINETEEN NINETY NINETEEN
NINETY ONE BUDGET --
THE FIRST SET SALES TAX SUGAR
WAS PASSED COUPLED WITH A SALES
TAX INCREASE OF THE EQUIVALENT
ONE QUARTER CENT ON AND THEN IN
THE TWO THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND
ONE SPENDING PLAN ON THE IDEA
WAS TO REDUCE THE THRESHOLD 23%.
JUST ONE LAST QUESTION HAS A
TRIGGER EVER BEEN PULLED
[inaudible]
YES WHAT'S WHEN WAS THAT.
WHO -- EARLY
TO MID TWO THOUSANDS ITEM OF THE
DAY OFF.
PICKY [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MISTER BENNETT.
SO OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE BEEN HAVING
THIS DISCUSSION FOR A COUPLE OF
WEEKS NOW BUT ANOTHER QUESTION
JUST A STATEMENT.
AS FAR AS I CAN TELL THE ONLY
REASON.
TO CREATE NEW TYPES OF BUDGET
SAID DEFICIT SAVINGS ACCOUNTS IS
TO AVOID.
LOWERING THE STATE SALES TAX
RATE AND GIVING THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA BREAK ON THEIR STATE
SALES TAX.
AND I THINK THAT'S
UNCONSCIONABLE IN AN ERA WHEN WE
HAVE A NINE BILLION DOLLAR
BUDGET SURPLUS.
OTHER COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
OKAY SEEING NONE I ANY MEMBERS
PUBLIC IN SUPPORT OF S..
BE.
EIGHT SIX FOUR THEY WANNA POST
DISPUTE.
SIX ONE OKAY SINGLE MOVE BONTA
SP IS SIX FIVE WHICH DEALS WITH
PROPOSITION TWO ALREADY
DIFFERENT.
MISTER CHAIR THIS GETS TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG SECONDARY
QUESTION ON THE PROPOSITION TWO
AND WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU REACH
THE CONSTITUTIONAL ON THRESHOLD
10%.
THE BILL SPECIFIES HOW PROP TO
INFRASTRUCTURE SPENDING WILL
OCCUR FOR TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AND 202-021-2120 TWO
FISCAL YEARS OF THE NEXT THREE
FISCAL YEARS.
THE FIRST FOREIGN FIFTEEN
MILLION LOSS AT GENERAL FUND
INFRASTRUCTURE SPENDING --
WITH AMOUNTS ABOVE THAT AND NOW
EVENLY ALLOCATED TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND HIGH PRIORITY RAIL
INVESTMENTS BUT THAT I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MISTREATMENT.
SO I THINK WHEN THE VOTERS
PASSED PROPERTY WILL AND WE TOLD
THEM THAT WE WERE GOING TO
INVEST.
THOSE ARE FUNDS AN
INFRASTRUCTURE THERE WERE%
PROBABLY THINKING ABOUT ROADS
AND BRIDGES AND AQUEDUCTS AND
DAMS AND THINGS LIKE THAT I
DON'T THINK THEY WERE TALKING
ABOUT [inaudible]
STATE.
BUILDINGS AND THAT'S WHAT THE
MAJORITY OF THE MONEY IN THIS
TRAILER BILL IS GOING TO WHAT I
WAS THE JUSTIFICATION FOR
PUTTING THAT MONEY. TO WARD
STATE BUILDINGS AND NOT TOWARDS
WHAT.
THEY A MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
MIGHT CONSIDER INFRASTRUCTURE.
PROP TO SPECIFICALLY REFERENCES
UP GOVERNMENT CODE SECTION ON
INFRASTRUCTURE EONS WE BELIEVE
THAT STATE BUILDINGS ARE
PERFECTLY PERMISSIBLE UNDER THAT
CODE SECTION.
I AGREE WITH YOU THAT IT'S
PERMITTED I JUST THOUGHT
THINKING THAT THE AVERAGE VOTER
WHO VOTED FOR PROP TWO WAS
THINKING ABOUT STATE BUILDINGS
WHEN WE USE THE WORD
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I DON'T THINK I CAN OPINE ON
WHAT VOTERS THOUGHT AT THE TIME
THAT THEY PASSED [inaudible]
PROP.
TWO THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS.
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT TO THE PUBLIC
[inaudible]
OTHER COMMENTS.
PUBLIC COME IT AGAINST.
OKAY SEEING NONE WE WILL MOVE ON
TO SB EIGHT SIXTY THE PUBLIC
SAFETY OF OCT.
THANK YOU THIS TRAILER BILL WILL
INCREASE OF FORTY THREE MILLION
LEASE REVENUE AUTHORITY FOR THE
HEALTH CARE FACILITIES
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM AND PROVIDE
NECESSARY REPORTING LANGUAGE TO
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE.
WE WOULD KNOW AND IT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO COMPLETE ALL
PROJECTS WILL LIKELY BE
NECESSARY.
THE ADMINISTRATION WILL CONTINUE
TO EVALUATE THE RESOURCE NEEDS
FOR THESE PROJECTS AND MAKE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCE REQUESTS AS
APPROPRIATE [inaudible]
THANK YOU. TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENT FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEN NOT ANY PUBLIC SUPPORT.
SEE NOT ANY PUBLIC OPPOSITION.
OKAY WE WILL MOVE ON TO SB EIGHT
SEVENTY WHICH IS THE NINE ONE
ONE FOUR THANK YOU THIS IS THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
TRAILER BILL THE BILL PERMITS
THE USE OF THE DISASTER RESPONSE
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS ACCOUNT.
FOR UP TO AN ADDITIONAL ONE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAYS AFTER
THE INITIAL ONE HUNDRED AND A
PERIOD.
IF THAT CHAIRPERSON OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE AND
THE CHAIR PERSONS OF THE FISCAL
COMMITTEES OF EACH HOUSE ARE
NOTIFIED.
THIS TRAILER BILL ALSO ON
CHANGES THE EXISTING --
AND NINE ONE ONE SUSTAINMENT
CHARGE OF THE EXISTING
SURCHARGES BASED ON AN
INTERSTATE VOICE COMMUNICATIONS
ORIGINATING WITHIN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATED WITH FIX LANDMINES
WIRELESS TELEPHONES AND VOICE
TELEPHONES.
THIS BILL REVISES THAT FREE
STRUCK THAT FEE STRUCTURE BY
IMPLEMENTING A FLAT RATE
SURCHARGE ON ALL ACCESS LINES
BEGINNING IN JANUARY ONE TWENTY
NINETEEN THIS BILL ALSO EXTENDS
THE MONTHLY SURCHARGE TO PREPAID
TELEPHONE SERVICES BEGINNING
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
WOULD KNOW THAT THE REVENUES
GENERATED FROM THIS WILL.
SUPPORT THE CURRENT LEGACY NINE
ONE ONE SYSTEM WHICH IS NO
LONGER I'M ABLE TO BE SUSTAINED
THROUGH OUR OLD FEE STRUCTURE.
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF NEXT
GENERATION THE REDUNDANT NETWORK
TO PROVIDE BETTER COMMUNICATIONS
DURING EMERGENCIES.
THANK YOU BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
IN THE COMING FOR THE COMMITTEE.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
FAVOR OF SB.
EIGHT SEVENTY ANY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC OPPOSED [inaudible]
OKAY.
WE DO WELL.
ADJOURNMENT WE WILL BE
RECONVENING MONDAY AT NOON. TO
FURTHER DISCUSS [inaudible]
WHICH ARE. TO FURTHER DISCUSS
ARE THE REMAINING TRAILER BILLS.
BUT THAT WE ARE JOB